a rising number of educators deciding to
leave clark county school district 8
news now reporter christine drummond
joining us live in the newsroom with the
issue and the concerns directly from
educators kristin
well each board meeting agenda lists the
teachers leaving documents from the last
three
board meetings show nearly 400 people
deciding to
not continue with ccsd a significant
jump from the list posted in january and
february
now the reasons why very but some
educators tell me
they're done just dissatisfied
dissatisfied
disgruntled and disappointed i have too
much experience and i have too much
education to be paid so low jeremy locke
says
low pay is one of the reasons he and his
wife plan to quit teaching in the clark
county school district
next month it's so political the duo
came here one year ago to continue
building their careers but
changed their mind about ccsd huge
problem of
valuing your people i see educators
making exit plans
national education association of
southern nevada president vicki kreidel
notices
this issue i personally know people who
just quit
and left because they don't feel
respected
the clark county education association
sent me a statement the teachers union
president says
the numbers we're seeing so far are
slightly higher than last year
however they are lower than years prior
to last it's hard to say for sure as we
won't know any final numbers
until the end of the school year ccsd
currently reports 479
current teacher vacancies that's around
2 percent of the roughly 18 thousand
educators in positions
ccsd normally reports a teacher shortage
at the beginning of each school year
it remains unknown if it may double as
more educators decide to leave next
month
how's the morale for you and how was it
among your colleagues
the morale has been a struggle for
everyone this year ryan framoltz does
not plan to leave his job despite his
concerns while he stays
the locks seek new opportunities in
education outside nevada
there's challenges to all districts
the district created a commission last
year to focus on recruiting
and retaining educators reporting in the
newsroom kristen drummond 8 news now